can't even cook here reporting live from
the Orlando Airport
you got your prospective
[Music]
or a water or a FLIR in 2016 morning I
have no idea what I said what I'm scared
about is you're all playing a game for
2016 that's in your vested interest as
you should because you're a human being
the problem is if you're not paying
attention the game that we're all gonna
be playing in 2026 they're gonna judge
you poorly please go look back at the
last three revolutions industrial
revolutions they're people that got hurt
the most look exactly like the people in
this room which was they were making
behavior for the prior game they were
training for basketball and the world
made them play hockey but I'm a very
funny feeling that I'm about to say the
same thing that's just the reality of a
game when you see the current
[Music]
and so I'm excited to give this keynote
I love this industry a lot a lot of
people in it I have no idea what I'm
going to talk about you're gonna die
it'll be consistent boss decides to chop
this up it probably gonna be funny I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
literally don't think I've ever had a
keynote where I'm more confused walking
into it which is crazy because I'm
deeply in the industry which speaks to
like the fun of this talk see good
morning
one thing I'd love to do is actually
encourage Q&A and I heard because I
haven't been here last couple days but
no human has come to the mic in the
entire three days so as much as I love
technology and absolutely like that I'd
love somebody to come up at some point
if they have a question when we
transition in about 20 minutes I would
say this one thing if you actually
believe something in a meeting and it
might be against the grain saying it in
respectful way matters because in three
years when it becomes true the other
seven people in that room will remember
that and that may lead to the growth in
your career that you're looking for
people think they grow in their career
by staying within the framework of their
organization they're actually quietly
subconsciously ruining their career if
they don't agree with the point of view
and I know for a fact because the best
part of can for me hands down is to 3
o'clock in the morning when people have
so much rose' in them they start talking
truth I know for a fact that there's a
lot of people that have strategies or
executions they don't personally believe
in it's just a framework of where the
margin is in their company or what they
have to be held accountable to a bonus
that's a tough life in in some way image
this is only just work there's much
bigger things going on but I will say
being on the record in a room
respectfully of what you actually
believe brave is a very very good idea
and honestly back to brave there's so
much content there's so much going on in
the world what I think this room
believes that defines is brave is
actually the only prayer to break
through consumer attention to make
something happen in your business thank
you thank you guys I think we need to
have more conversations around
self-awareness and happiness agree so
why is that not people insecure okay but
you don't think people obviously I mean
two points they're thinking about these
things they go today have the rose day
oh you mean the pipe ah there's not even
like marketing-wise like it's heavy [ __ ]
for humans it's those important right
the good news is you don't have to you
can control what you can control right
of course that's it so I can speak into
creating myself but that's what I live I
do what I do and without content about
my beliefs on it some people connect
with it you move forward yeah can't boil
the ocean you know yes I know do it
just focus on your [ __ ] and do it and
then you'll inspire others to do good
Arman thank you
the point is we all here like have a
obligation to try to make something
happen for our businesses and I say with
that dollar Lori what can you do best
and to me we cloud it with like lines
and it's like different points like to
me it's just like every day every day
you must linked it right now my life is
linked in organic
content because the organic reaches
through the roof like Facebook seven
years ago and I'm going to squeeze the
[ __ ] out of it and as soon as it goes
away I'm like [ __ ] that I've built my
whole life on Google AdWords I spend
nothing on Google AdWords in that press
when I tell you on my kids that in the
next half decade it's gonna be 500 times
worse it is the singular reason I think
a company that is as great as yours
could actually look like Sears and I
really believe that yes if you do not
build up your dtc capabilities without
causing conflict in your channels you'll
go out of it and that's the hard part I
know this is real yeah I'm telling you
there is a naivete in this collective of
what's about to happen and the only
thing that is actually ownable and
controllable is contemporary marketing
to build brand so you can trade on that
only currency because if you are not
selling direct to consumer you are now
100% vulnerable I decided to start my
year this year starting my day with
thank you
really feeling outside like my whole
team took every day I like quoting Effie
I've been paying 100% like in every
hundred percent 100 percent anyway do
you feel like it's impacted my energy
like I'm so passionate about all of it
and like someone was like this yesterday
was like why do you love Gary Vee and I
know you pushed press it a lot but for
me Thank You economy was like here
I push happiness and self-awareness much
more than crushing it it's just crushing
against all the attention because it's a
lightning bolt of like Oh see hearts
overwork like people are looking for
things people if you listen it's very
clear it's my it's my primitive frame of
mind it's it's having a really awesome
mother having a lot of adversity as a
kid circumstances it's like I take no
pride or like yeah like it comes
naturally you know some people can sing
some people things are just very clear
human behavior is very clear to me like
being a retailer throwing up as a
retailer is a big advantage you know
every day Courtney Laurie Katie they
come in every day was like I have this
party for white like everything all I
ever knew was this prick this person
needs something they're in my
neighborhood I can milk her for a wine
that I'm making more money on but based
on what she said if I ever want her to
come back I better give her the right
thing being a retailer in a family
business in her neighborhood is an
incredible framework for being consumer
centric in hindsight never this probably
last two years are like wait a minute
maybe this is why and then just being
kind I'm a kind guy I like doing others
plus if you're running a marathon you do
long-term behavior if you're running a
sprint you do short-term behavior so I
think that is also an advantage for us
can't even shook here reporting live
from the Orlando Airport where once
again he hit the stage and he did what
he had to do which is be historically
correct and speak is truth and anybody
who speaks their truth with the hope of
being historically correct tend to win
the marathon life is a marathon unless
you get hit by a bus
[Music]
you